welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Vasa and the Batman with Robert
Pattinson in the cow gave us our first
official look at the character and test
footage and now some set photos and
video have revealed brucey in action or
I should say a stunt double that
weirdly looks a lot like Ben Affleck I
miss his life put me back in there
actually a number of interesting visual
clues in this costume design we actually
already started breaking down a lot of
clues in the new bat suit and the recent
episode of the big question
you really gotta check that out but here
I'm gonna break down the new things we
found and what this footage could tell
us about this movie's story because
honestly it's probably a little sooner
rush to judgment over whether the cowl
and ears match what was in your head and
I'm gonna explain why you can spare your
talk yeah that includes you bale spoiler
warning in case any of this is revealing
too much about the movie for you even
though I do not have any insight
information about this movie's plot this
is really the speculation using the same
covered eyes and standing ears that we
all have okay the imagery shows Batman
on what looks like a new bad cycle with
spiky bat ears on the handlebars that
will definitely poke out someone's eye
as he rides through cemetary with a
female companion some of whom are saying
could be Selina Kyle Catwoman this angle
Batman shows us the ears of Batman's
cowl which looks sharp as hell like a
bit thorny as if his head was covered in
tar and just like pinched and stretched
up into two points if you think the
silhouette looks stupid don't worry just
to kind of rotate it to the side and hey
looks a lot more classic as we
speculated from the test footage the
eyepieces are indeed covered make me
think at least this cowl could be a kind
of biker helmet most eyepieces could be
goggles his shoulders and arms are
covered in heavy padding but most
interesting to me are his gauntlets they
are lined with these metallic pointed
quills maybe some kind of projectiles
that fire off or you know maybe just
pins for a Batman to try to replicate
the Joker's magic trick some have
pointed out that these gauntlets
resemble the ones worn by Talon Talon is
a DC character kind of villain turned
Batman Ally former assassin for Gotham's
courts of age a shadowy cult that
secretly controls the city similar to
how the League of Shadows was depicted
in Chris Nolan's Batman Begins
but going further down the suit
could see a holster and some pouches
maybe for a Batman's grappling gun and
his chest emblem looks even more
detachable and weapony here with handles
not unlike the broken pieces of a gun
like the gun that killed his parents but
even more clearly here you can see the
edges of the wings look sharpened as if
edges of knives and again check out that
episode a big question to see us reverse
engineering this Mythbusters style to
determine whether it's more likely a
Batarang or two knives back-to-back we
use science we figured it out and you'll
notice on the stunt actors face or if
you dots those are likely for the VFX
team to digitally cover the stand in
space with Robert Pattinson's beautiful
face remember as we saw in the video it
is raining the roads are slippery you do
not want pretty boy Edward II MIT day 1
a production now Batman
on his bat cycle like this may remind
you of the Batman 0 year comics but
there is enough context here to actually
start to piece together some of the
story of this movie
ok this imagery is coming from the
Batman's production in Glasgow Scotland
atop a hill in the city to the east of
glasgow cathedral is the victorian-era
necropolis cemetery that's what this is
now Batman could be in a cemetery for
any number of reasons he's kind of a
gloomy Gus visiting the graves of I
don't know Thomas and Martha Wayne would
probably be a bit ill-advised while
you're also taking the trouble to
disguise yourself as a Batman the graves
of the Wayne's Moors are that said this
movies working title is vengeance and as
we explored in the last episode of rogue
theory it would be very interesting to
see a Batman motivated by revenge for
the murder of Dick Grayson or Jason Todd
I know you're gonna say this will be a
younger Bruce Wayne and classically
Batman as a team up with a Robin figure
until he's a bit older but maybe
director Matt Reeves is exploring a
version of Batman in which he begins his
vigilante journey as part of a
partnership but then loses that partner
in the first year where the reason
people are pushing this is there have
been some casting rumors seeking circus
skills with some chatter that Timothy
sha'lame could be a good fit in some
kind of flying Grayson backstory there
have also been some photos taken around
the Glasgow area showing signs for a
Gotham renewal corporation investing in
our future Gotham orphanage orphanage
you know how people put up signs for
orphanages all over the place hey yeah
look away
good about your city's future by
thinking about a bunch of kids whose
parents died don't cry do are on your
way to work folks and Batman math an
orphanage and the movie equals a Robin
figure in the movie but while we're
considering rumor and speculation
another report I think is very important
to keep in mind is that we could be seen
to bat suits in this film so if you are
not a fan of the suit in these set
photos and videos we could just be
looking at an early prototype that gets
replaced or destroyed early on in the
film as is often the case in movies of
this genre it's also possible that we're
looking at a beefed-up version of the
suit with padding specifically just for
the stunt performer and the one
Pattinson suits up in for close-ups will
be trimmed down for a better silhouette
ultimately what interests me most about
these images is the fact that Batman is
joined by this other character she's got
a helmet on and it's likely another
stunt actor but one well-known dark clad
Gotham woman who drives a motorcycle is
Selina Kyle well I guess Huntress - but
you know I don't see a crossbow and she
already got a movie Batman's
relationship with Catwoman has often
been somewhat altruistic but if we
assume that this is early in a film with
like that suit being replaced sometime
later maybe there will be an early
partnership between Batman and Selina
Kyle that doesn't last forever our buddy
Jeff pitched a pretty great theory about
Batman and Catwoman 'he's dark love
affair in this film that i just really
enjoyed be sure to check that out now
when these photos and videos dropped we
were all over them in new rockstars
official discord server alternate
theories for Batman's new gauntlets
how much he weighs just by eyeballing it
our discord is really the place where
the unfiltered conversation is going on
between our staff and our inner circle
of supporters you could join our discord
today by becoming a patron of new rock
stars at patreon.com slash new rock
stars comment down below with your
thoughts on this new Batman suit follow
me Eddie a vos followed new rock stars
and social media and subscribe to me
rock stars are breakdowns of everything
you love thank you for watching and hey
Gotham's future lookin bright ik if
someone keeps burning all the Morphin
itches the parents are dead now they're
homeless - but then fires the blight so
you need goggles on your stabby Batman
[Music]